[Music]
all right in just two hours one minute
i've been telling you my book live free
or die america in the world on the brink
is finally
out and by the way thank you you've
already made a number one non-picture on
amazon.com
we can't do this without you thank you i
think it's important the country is on
the brink
by the way it's now discounted there at
amazon.com
34 i don't know who decided that but i'm
happy that's good because i want to get
the message out
first book in 10 years also on
hannity.com we have a list
of events that we'd love to invite you
to for
the book and we'd love to have you
participate in them
again number one amazon thanks to you we
also have our election interactive map
hannity.com that means you'll know uh
when is early voting star in your state
who is running for your congressional
seat what about absentee voting
you know what all hands on deck moment
for the country
quick programming you know it'll be on
fox and friends tomorrow 8 a.m
let not your heart be troubled because
i'm about to get beaten up by laura
ingraham so my heart has to be troubled
are you ready are you ready that's the
great way the best way to start
interviewing
are you ready oh man
you think going on the view is difficult
all right
you know but you're kind of pals with
behar in the crowd right now i'm just
kidding
joyless no she hates can i tell you a
quick funny story if you're interested
yeah last time i was on the view rosie
o'donnell was there
barbara walters was there and it became
in honor of adam schiff a
shift show and barbara god bless her
she couldn't stop it it was she went
crazy and i just haven't been back often
i used to go on it occasionally it's
hard-hitting news show it's too tough no
i remember once uh
i remember once baehart and she's kind
of funny i mean
i i you have to just take people as they
come i mean she's outraged liberal but
she's funny
and she said laura barbara streisand's a
very patriotic person laura stop
criticizing barbara streisand it was the
funniest because i
you know wrote that book shut up and
sing and it was she was very
upsetting too what do you love about new
york accent that sort of sounds like
where do you walkers
we're prepared we have the best yeah all
right we gotta talk
we gotta talk your book cause in moments
uh i am
going to be exclusively interviewing
mike pence so he's
following you and then given the left's
attempts to keep kids out of school
sean we're gonna they're trying to keep
them out of even parochial
independent and private schools in the
montgomery county
uh suburb of dcf so i'm going to get to
that but we have to get to your book and
i can't believe you only hit
number one that is so lame live free or
die which is just out and
is it out in like two hours is it just
two hours and you can actually
spend one one hour and to be exact
58 minutes but i'm not counting okay so
how do you arrange to be number one is
that just
pre-orders or do you pay for anything
with the selling of anything oh you buy
new books
or no no i don't know i'm not involved
in
selling anything what i do know this
because of code we know things were
going to be different we put up all
these
cool events that we're doing we're
asking people to join on hannity.com
but i i have signed if i told you how
many
you wouldn't believe stop bragging i was
that no i mean because i wanted it
because i would normally go on a book
tour like you've done i have a question
when you do signing because of all your
mixed martial arts do you like flex
when you sign and go like like that like
you're like do you like conflict
seriously
when you're doing you're just like about
my three older sisters you just
like to torture me i know you have great
pleasure in this
no i'm serious i'm so proud of you
because you haven't had a book in a
while
and that's why it's flying off the
shelves of course and
and it's going to be number one in every
category which i i i'm so
i hate writing books it's too hard it's
very hard yeah
yeah it takes a lot of time all right i
want to get to some serious questions
because people actually want me to ask
some serious questions so
three months we have the election all
right and and things seem
to be shifting i think into
trump's direction who knows what the
polls are saying but
is it the riots that's moving uh middle
america
back toward trump the school issue or
all of the above what is it
it's a great question and i can give you
i'll try and be very quick with my
answers which is hard for me
i think it's a combination of wow the
left has embraced
anarchy they're not supporting safety
and security law and order
uh obama's speech wow could it get any
more divisive than last week
joe biden and i think this is a sign of
pure weakness
that now he had to shore up his own
base because he wasn't confident
bolshevik bernie's
uh followers and their cult like would
vote for him
so he had literally like he always does
plagiarizes a lot
he plagiarized bolshevik bernie's
economic agenda
that is the hardest left he's pledging
trillions for aoc's green new deal
you know his guns are as the guy that
wants to confiscate guns
i would argue laura and when i i started
this project about a year ago
thinking that this was going to be the
moment i really did i believe that
where it was going to be the biggest
choice election and so much was at stake
and i swore 10 years ago i wouldn't
write another book but i needed to get
it down because
even four hours a day i can't get it all
out with the history i want to give
it's even worse than i thought it would
be
because i we when do we ever see a
presidential candidate
usually see candidates go to the base to
get a nomination
move to the center in a general election
two exceptions to that rule would be
ronald reagan and donald j trump
they donald j trump's predictable he's
he kept all his promises that he made
and he never changed
you and i vouched for his conservative
governance when so many of our fellow
conservatives have never happened i know
they did
they ditched him um okay we got to talk
because i'm about to talk to the vice
president so i have to ask you
the top rush me out of the way shush me
away i got it sorry pence you know what
can i do
more importantly i agree he doesn't have
the number one book but he is the vice
president
okay vice presidential contenders all
right kamala harris susan rice
uh commie karen bass tammy duckworth
elizabeth warren
okay out of all of these possibilities
who's
the worst since your book is about
freedom liberty
live free or die who would be the worst
for preserving
our civil liberties that are under
assault right now
one observation first that is that
historically
vice presidential selections they're
they're
they're not gonna they're not gonna it's
usually do no harm that's what you want
um in a vice presidential selection
people pick the top of the ticket
the one thing i would argue everybody in
this modern extreme democratic socialist
party has
is their radical left they all have that
in common
and which fits into what joe has done
and
i don't know how you allow all these
liberal cities that can't restore law
and order
how do i rule one who's the worst for
civil liberties on that list
who among those those i don't see one
person that is really
on ideology that different they're all
they're all
left all four left i think look
it it's really important that you wrote
this book at this time
everybody go out and get it i live for
your die is
i mean that that's why our country's
special because of our freedom even
though you're my like my three older
sisters you're a dear friend
i appreciate your support i'll be on fox
and friends tomorrow but
listen the support of my friends and
colleagues means more than anything
and we can't do this without we talk
about this a lot
this wonderful loyal supportive audience
they give us the screen
they give us our radio shows and they're
making it possible but
i have a five alarm fire in my head
and my my heart and my soul if we
if if these policies are enacted it will
be a disaster for the country
and the suffering real suffering sean
congrats on the book
thank you for having me absolutely
always there for you
sean congratulations we really
appreciate it